salut la team mentale aujourd'hui je
suis avec céline lenski elle sait que
c'est elle et vous vous savez déjà que
c'est elle parce qu'on a déjà fait des
vidéos ensemble plus précisément une
celle ci quand on était à londres au
début de l'année tu te souviens oh là là
ce temps magnifique a le même que
maintenant exactement comme l'a amené de
londres on l'a gardée depuis le mois de
janvier for an qu'on parte ailleurs vous
la voyez aussi des fois dans le fond de
certains mentale blogs ont la voix qui
disparaît qui s'en occupe on a une
fenêtre se nomme les spectres finalement
il ya quelques temps tu as emile envie
d'avoir toi aussi un vrai quelque chose
pour toi l'évolution rébellion y en a
marre c'est tout bon pour les autres et
moi a juste un cobaye
donc c'est spontanément les embiez
plaisir que je dis bah tiens on va faire
la vidéo du vendredi ensemble ont fait
cette vidéo là ensemble j'ai pas voulu
te mentaliser pourquoi parce que j'ai
pensé un petit truc qu'on pourrait faire
ensemble dans six mois je te le dirai
tout à l'heure c'est une surprise
ça fait très longtemps que j'ai pas fait
une magie moi-même sur la chaîne donc je
te faire un tour à tour avec un petit
paquet de cartes où il ya des petites
cartes être on se demande si je vais
dire le mot petit à chaque fois que je
parle j'ai des cartes avec moi je
voulais fait voir jeter les filets voir
également
ok ça va tu les vois si je recule tu me
dis que tu choisis une carte celle que
tu veux dans le hasard le plus complet
s'il te plaît pas tu changes de cartes
elle te plaît ou pas aller elle me plaît
c'est vrai tu l'as fait bien voir tout
le monde s'il te plaît sauf à moi
évidemment c'est bon c'est bon
es-tu là repose et moi je referme le jeu
j'égalise bien y'a pas de break de
choses comme ça c'est bien refermée ça
marche
est ce que tu te souviens bien de la
phase de ta carte oui oui est ce que tu
te suis un maire du 2 ta carte
bah oui donc c'était un document rouge
en fait je t'avais dit que je faisais un
tour de magie c'est en fait une petite
mentalisation c'est à dire que je
voulais faire voir que les gens ne
prêtait pas attention aux choses et en
fait t'as pas prêté attention comme pour
toi tous les deux étés rouge t'as jamais
fais gaffe qui avait un double un double
un seul double un double et un seul
double n'y a pas de double il ya qu un
seul double c'est ce que tu peux me dire
quelle était ta carte s'il te plaît
banja retour le 7 de trèfle qui est donc
la carte que toi tu avais choisi par
contre j'étais promis un petit tour de
magie
donc on va essayer de rendre c'est un
peu plus magique tu peux te tendre la
main comme ça la propre non je déconne
pourtant c'est celle ci qui finit sur
mesure générale tu mets l'autre main
comme ça par dessus pour être sûr que je
puisse pas prendre la carte somme
qu'elle saisira jamais jamais je vais te
demander de choisir une carte est ce que
tu peux sortir ta troisième main n'en
cherche pas à tourner la page en suis
quasiment certain
du coup tu vas me dire stop quand tu
veux stop tu retiens la carte oui tu
retiens la carte vous pourriez répondre
quand je parle du jeu le but mais j'en
ai rien à faire de retenue la carte est
ce que tard que le dos de la carte
elle ne dit pas qui leur conseillait
alors alors non en fait si tu te fais
mien je t'ai fait voir la carte cueilli
que y'avait en dessous quand tu m'as dit
stop donc on n'a pas pu voir le dos le
dos était cachée et je peux toutes
manières prouver qu'il n'y a pas
d'autres double il ya qu un seul double
il ya qu un seul double et si ça se
trouve tout ce qui s'est passé
précédemment était simplement une
illusion un sentiment de déjà vu
peut-être que t'as jamais eu cette de
trêve de la même peut-être que le set de
trèfle a toujours eu un dos rouge
peut-être même qu'il est dans ce jeu là
est ce que tu peux me dire qu'elle car
tu as vu après où tu as khroub cru voir
pdf
c'était 3-2 car trois coeurs peut-être
je sais pas moi je les ai pas vus est ce
que toi tu peux retourner les mains
comme ça et les ouvrir et à la derrière
tu as juste une carte et une seule carte
adroit de coeur à double et non à 7,2
trèche merci beaucoup
céline ce qui est là mais ouais pas mal
c'est pas marrant c'est bien dans ces
versets la gcc comme lapiro quoi c'est
toi petit sigle 0 merci merci beaucoup
merci à toi d'être venu te faire
mentaliser non te faire magique et
mentalisme magique et on va dire sur la
chaîne aujourd'hui j'ai promis quelque
chose c'est que comme ça faisait six
mois tu étais pas venu sur la chaîne je
te propose de revenir dans six mois
en fait céline elle m'a déjà raconté
qu'elle et aller voir des hypno
thérapeutes
oui des hypnotiseurs des sites nos
thérapeutes c'était pour arrêter de
fumer
oui et ça n'a pas marché baba cool ça va
pas franchement marché j'avais de la
peine pour lui parce qu'apparemment je
n'avais pas suffisamment de réaction et
je sentais qu'il en attendait lune puis
grossesse et même pire que ça c'est que
lui s'est mis à fumer après ça alors
qu'il fumait pas du tout aisée c'est
terrible personne n'a jamais réussi à
les finaliser donc je te propose dans
six mois de revenir sur la chaîne et moi
j'essaierai de qui tu me disais est ce
que je peux signer par contre d'une
clause de fait pas tout ce truc chelou
après non mais je commence par annoncer
la macarena ce que j'ai en tête le
carnage trouvé ça plutôt cool ont fait
l'un des meilleurs d'ici là je vais un
peu parler dit mot sur la chaîne le plus
tôt dans la deuxième partie de l'année à
partir du mois de septembre
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère que ça vous a plu si c'est le
cas faites le nous savoir en nous
laissant un petit mais néanmoins très
agréable ou sans l'air n'hésitez pas non
plus à nous laisser un commentaire
pourquoi pas parce que déjà je vis tous
et j'y réponds en fin de semaine en
général le dimanche ou le samedi mais
surtout parce que l'activité préférée de
céline au yen ce qui est de lire vos
commentaires
mais c'est vrai on peut sur les lis
souvent ouais c'est un petit peu ma télé
réalité à moi aussi comme ça que j'ai un
truc chez lui des fois il ya des
conversations doucement ah oui alors je
m'y colle claudine cette phrase on va
voir mais c'est claudine
n'hésitez pas donc à mettre à court
terme est également de vous abonner à la
chaîne avant de partir pourquoi parce
que le mental blog c'est une vidéo par
jour pendant un an donc rendez vous
demain à 11 heures parce que demain
c'est samedi
ciao